wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ihre bestellungen zahlen sie zusammen
oder getrennt zusammen was kostet das
die drei pizza mit salami sind 22 50
dann haben wir eine pizza thunfische
eine pizza hawaii ohne schinken 18 euro
macht zusammen 40 auf 50 10 die bade mit
karte zahle war diesem 45 euro
das stimmt sagt danke hier ist die
rechnung danke
so bekommt die arbeit ohne lohn salami
und noch eine salami spiel kostet die
plätze zehn euro plus trinkgeld und du
bist eingeladen dankeschön
das ist vielleicht die letzte persönlich
hier essen werde bestimmt nach wien geht
weg das ist eine party eine
abschiedsparty
abschnitts guten ansätze